all right boys we're gonna end it with
some king of their stinger and wrap it
up there
uh first this is adam from cape town
south africa ooh beautiful oh we're
going
international babe mr worldwide
what's up fear what's up brandon
this is adam coming to you from sunny
cape town south africa
you know what it is for the king of the
stinger for you
slacklining first buzz
buzz buzz that's some white [ __ ] isn't
it black lining have you ever seen
anyone but a white person walk a line
like that
ever you ever seen in the search
everything cops dude a lot of black
dudes doing it
okay and i'm gonna talk about that
johnny cash movie look at that sorry
i'm just saying i think it's a universal
sport
i definitely don't you ever seen the
circus have you ever seen
anyone besides a white person on the top
of the ropes like this
you're seeing a [ __ ] black dude doing
that
that's a good point let's go to the
culture corner and find out
is ropewalk in a black or white event or
is it
is it cultural what's going on yeah it's
cultural as the whitest [ __ ] that's ever
existed
in white culture that's what it is for
sure
i have yet to see anybody but a white
person do it really
it's as white as a [ __ ] blink 182
concert bro
yeah the only black person adam was
little wayne and he [ __ ] left the buy
and try
the only two black people ever chapelle
lacy and lil wayne
and lil wayne's out i feel like there's
like some chinese girl somewhere out
there doing it right now though
yeah somewhere i feel like if there's
anyone to do it's like a tiny chinese
girl
um chinese they call it the tinies
it's white though it's a skill i guess
it also takes a lot of time
i mean a lot of time it's way quicker
than going all the way downstairs and
walking across the street and going all
the way upstairs if you have a rope
yeah you're right you're right it's
definitely a white
sport slack lining uh
huh it's brave man is it he's two feet
off the ground
okay it's not that brave now for you to
do in the circus you can do it from
building to building now over at tiger's
mouth yeah if you're gonna be spider-man
with it
tarzan i'm with it yeah but if you're
just in your backyard above your [ __ ]
flower garden
and calling it dangerous you get a
little living to do
yeah especially in your country in south
africa uh you gotta hit up um
they have one of the largest bungee
jumps in the whole world i think it's
there actually off the
blue cranes bridge or something see
where it's at hey would you order a
bungee jump
huh would you have a bungee jump yeah
i've done it a couple times i wouldn't
do it again that's for dum-dums man
i wouldn't do it again it's always now
it's always like over there in
uh you know pompano beach or something
or delray beach now it's in cancun
it's at the blue cranes bridge 10
highest bungies in the world
it's fourth place derek using his
motor skills obviously obviously he was
on scholarship was it
was it struggle city or whatever bro was
it struggle buster
you think you'd have been over there
uh but tell us about it derek um it's
the blue cron's
bridge bungie it's the world's highest
commercial bungee
at 216 meters that's 709 feet yeah walk
across that bro and get back to me i had
a chance to go on this one time when i
chickened out because you're you're
smart-ish
yeah it just i think i had too much bad
experiences in america where it's like
some guy's like oh you could handle it
you know
and he hooks you and he has you hooked
up and then one guy's like all this jump
he's like hold on we got to hook you no
no no do you see the guy whose cord
broke you see that
uh there's recently in the news i forget
where i saw jude jump
the court was like nah not up in here
broke
they went straight to the ground but
there was a thing to catch him
underneath
he broke his back neck he's still alive
breaking my back freaking my knees
in the front broke in the back
uh not a slack lining though bro but
yeah man you're in the you're in a
country that has
x games are thriving over there dude i
think put that slack line
you know how about this take it from
your wife's bedroom window y'all's
bedroom window over to the neighbor's
window
start somewhere see how that line works
yeah real neighbors
get risky bro you know how the same time
you're super risky start doing over the
ocean with all the goddamn great whites
jumping out of the water that'll be a
sight oh put a little risk and you
triscuit bro you feel me dog yeah
gang man